it's time to play hashtag to end all war
and then I had a very powerful impact on
television comedy most of all Twitter as
every night we make people all over the
globe say why the is my timeline
full of snake bands the hashtagwars been
the cornerstone of our show since the
very first one film poops which is a
very first hashtag where we ever did so
tonight we are blowing things out with
the hashtag to end all hashtagwars we're
going to fly through a bunch of hashtags
which can change it anytime because
commitment is hard you guys and because
I've spent so people always say like how
come you never play the game why don't
you leverage let someone jump in and you
do the thing I go I just never felt
right about it before and after years of
giving other people points tonight I
want to step into the ring I'm going to
give a comedian some serious pun for
their money
so Tom lemon if you would be so kind you
come to
Oh sample deficits go low it will never
come back never never find us
yeah it's never coming back ever coming
back ladies on hockey let's play the
half scheduled to end all hack I've Wars
first up get TV Gordon uh cadaver on
ACCA's closet hi Ron punching apparently
any show I'm on more than one episode uh
oh my god one Chris don't head to you
Ron I got it I got to get mine out so
competing faces
rigor mortis yeah Chris Hardwick Full
House of 1000 corpses that's ten ago
don't ring it until I call on you
this isn't the wall harlot
help I need somebody hot sauce for men
my neck my back my octopus in my crab
yes thanks move fish get out the way
[Applause]
Satan pause here puede de yay supports
away give it 3 a.m. to get breastfed hi
hey Jen Saturday night my baby's got a
fever soulless ginger backside so
there's always remain Tyler Perry's a
diary of a mellow black woman
Hardwick The Merchant of Venice Beach
nice fine local joke you should be Man
of La Mancha hi show me animal movies
yes
Conan the Barbarian you know like oh
yeah I guess shuffle boys thank you
harlot who's afraid of this actual wolf
Sherman house of a thousand corgis
dioxide a horny beetle April while my
guitar gently creeps
alright heartless
Lucy in this guy with diamond boy Rick
Eleanor tug me
showing new drug videogames gin and
Sonic Jonah ray very tight Matt Myra
Batman drunken asylum coin Harwick
legend of zelda breathalyzer of the wild
point reptile Club Hardwick croc Adele
hi boy
hello Amelia I'm Neeson point will weird
alligator
Oh Joey had a TV show ruin a TV show hit
me
Hardwick Doctor Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire
points a gate The Cosby Tyler Moore Show
point Rob Huebel the big Burn Notice
full sold only with enthusiasm you
chronic RuPaul's Drag net hike
Steve Agee Dora the Bachelorette you bow
I didn't call you yet sir Charles in
charge of the blacklist Holly wrote a
song hit me where dolly I canna carry on
my wayward son of a preacher man of
constant sorrow
[Music]
retentive in his Brenda's Kris triple
points were in his domain somehow triple
points hard wet back that ass up up and
away in my beautiful balloon off on
Ricky who let the dogs out of my dreams
and into my car next up show me fart
celebs Hardwick crop Dustin Hoffman ha
ha point Brennan
Charlize Theron for some reason double
points that I've alright right IRA gasps
ha ha ha ha ha
perfect show me Bart Broadway kinky
toots what army cheese is cut super
[Applause]
- Berlin stink 182 points of course all
right Brown Sabbath Jose the poo
fighters ha ha actually guys in five
words memory learned lots about male
ejaculation boy you know perky
pre-apocalyptic pop culture round hoping
against hope that one black at a time
I can't be true
one girl at a time Kirk fun TV times
with friends oh I hope that gets
on the show
[Applause]
mr. Paul talking no greatest audiences
in the world
that's job I ever had oh I know but it's
why
[Applause]